hi everyone I'm here today with John
dents who is a lecturer in physics here
at the ANU and John is also involved a
lot in the maker space here at amu I
thought I'd talk to you John to get your
perspective on a few of my most asked
questions relating to physics and
relating to studying physics because I
think you know you're a lecturer you've
done your PhD you might have a better
perspective on it than I do so just for
a bit of context what was your maybe
your PhD area and what you're interested
in now so I I did my PhD in quantum
physics so really cold atom and pulling
him down it was experimental so although
we did a little bit of theoretical work
as well we typically worked with
theorists and I was on the experimental
side so building and making was a big
part of that and in fact a lot of the
physics learning I did I feel like a lot
of the skills and the really deep
understanding came out of that
experimental work that sounds like you
see physics as a very valuable skill to
have for knowledge you know as a toolset
yeah I would say the toolbox of a
physicist is somewhat unique in society
the approach to problem solving being
able to quickly estimate things in fact
check so you do think there are jobs for
physics majors out there would you say
you know physics is a good major to set
you up in life I don't know anyone who's
done a degree in physics particularly at
a great institution but but anywhere
that has found it hard to find a job
afterwards yeah now that may not be a
job that is particularly physics II but
in terms of their skill set and the
transferability of that skill set it's
really high yeah well it's kind of nice
to hear that because I think I've seen
it a code among like undergrad students
in physics even they're sort of worried
about what they're going to do after
because we hear a lot that there are not
many jobs in the academic pathway maybe
postdoc positions and so we're told to
expect to go out into the workforce but
maybe a lot of people aren't willing to
give up you know doing pure physics and
and do something more in industry so I
think there's an element of that and I
think a lot of people who
sort of end up falling in love with
physics like solving little puzzles and
are used to seeing textbook problems and
getting through them and knowing they
got the right answer and so on it
actually turns out that even in the
world of academic physics that's not the
case I'm sure you know that often the
answers are not clear the data is noisy
trying to draw a conclusion things
didn't work the way you expected them to
I actually found that the correlation
between doing well at physics exams and
doing well at physics research was not
necessarily high like you maybe use a
different part of your brain to do the
physics research because you really are
no right answers and if you're used to
getting right answers from the physics
exams and the assignments mmm I don't
know they're not quite all the same no I
don't think this strongly correlated and
I think that the way that physics is
traditionally taught doesn't necessarily
train people well for being good
researchers but it does train them on
how to build models of the world and
things yeah and so for a lot of students
they probably don't realize it and I
think it is something we don't do well
enough is giving our students the way
the kind of the pathway to other options
you are yes you're doing physics but
actually this applies to a whole bunch
of other things and for a long time the
finance sector was snapping up
physicists because it is about building
models of observations and you know
based on data you can do that for all
sorts of systems not just you know balls
moving through the air I have heard of
the physics majors going into finance so
I guess maybe the advices for someone
that's you know wanting to a physics
major about worried about jobs at the
end maybe to sort of think broad cuz
there your skills are valuable so you
shouldn't maybe doubt that well I think
I think that people should always follow
their passions and so if you're really
passionate about physics or science in
general I think physics is a really
great starting point for getting that
training in critical thinking model
building numbers mathematics and so on
but keep your eyes open take a few
electives in other other areas what else
you interested in because it's probably
more than just physics and see how you
might
you know be hungry and go out and see
how you might apply those skills because
it will lead you to being highly
employable and I think more and more
society is actually starting to value
and and realize that those critical
thinking skills do emerge naturally from
people to study physics that you can get
them other ways you can get them from
other degrees but a lot of it is
actually you know people have often told
me you've really got to kind of make the
job that you want yeah yeah and you got
to have a think about what it is you
want and and often people when they go
into university particularly if they
just go straight from high school into
university they don't really know the
answer to that question yeah ok well
that's I think a good thing to keep in
mind so another question I guess related
as I have had people say to me you know
physics is my passion I really want to
do physics but maybe my parents tell me
that there's no money in physics
compared to something like engineering
and I've had people comment you know I
love physics but I'm going to major in
engineering so that I can make money
what's your opinion on the engineering
major I see a lot of similarities
between physicists and engineers and in
my opinion I think you could sort of do
either degree and end up maybe at the
same place but what do you think um so I
think it's a very complex question and
there's a lot of facets to it absolutely
traditional engineering where you're
designing something to solve a problem
and you're building it relies on a lot
of physics and any in my opinion any
good engineering degree should cover a
good amount of physics the the thing
about a degree that's often perceived by
people in society I think is that they
associate the name of the degree or the
major with a job
engineer right and so if you do physics
you're a physicist if you do biology
you're a biologist if you do medicine
you become a doctor right and there are
a few degrees where that's kind of true
and they're the the degrees that are
linked to professions so things like
engineering and medicine and law the
kind of classic things people went to
university for
you you kind of have to do them to enter
that profession in fact if you really
want to work as an engineer which means
having that title and being able to sign
off on you know that this building is
stable that this air conditioning system
can provide the cooling or heating load
required for the building you have to do
an engineering degree to be accredited
by the professional charter of Engineers
right certification now if what you're
interested in is like building the
future electric car and working at a
place like you know Tesla or or just
solving interesting problems working
with data and big data ions then they're
really I agree there really is no
difference and actually in my experience
people that have a good solid foundation
in physics become better engineers than
people that kind of drive straight into
the engineering without that
foundational base I'm not saying that
you can't have both but but you need to
sort of if you're looking for a degree
that kind of has a bit of both pick a
dig into the degree more than just the
fact that it's called an engineering
degree look at what courses are being
taught and maybe who they're being
taught by what faculties and so on
because having that foundation in that
foundational knowledge and approach in
physics makes you really understand how
the world works how materials respond
how a design might might be impacted by
that and I think that's what people are
interested in when they say to me they
love physics and want to make a career
out of it they're interested in that
aspect of it so I think that was a
really good way to put it yeah what you
actually want to do not what you want to
be yeah yeah yeah and some and some I
think some institutions will you know
they will just have a little bit more
physics in the degree than others some
people take the approach of doing a
double degree where they actually do a
science degree in engineering and that's
actually a really powerful combination
it takes more time of course the other
option is that you can do a science
degree in three years and then you can
do a masters of engineering where you
get that accreditation you get to dive
into the design and the professional
principles of engineering but you
started from having a pretty broad base
I think that idea of starting quite
broad
specializing when you get to masters or
something people forget you can do and
they get too worried about picking their
first-year courses to be everything
they're interested in but they can you
know specialize in that later on yeah
and I and I can't recommend enough the
value of doing electives outside of that
discipline area I think in Australia
especially the there's a sort of a focus
on specializing and taking that thing
right right at the beginning but you
know if you're inserting a language if
you're interested in the arts if you're
using things like out of science like
the apt hybrid totally it will make you
a more holistic person member of society
employee I think the importance of
communicating when you're a physics and
engineer is like a whole nother so
absolutely like it's such an important
part of your job definitely yeah
alright I think that's some really good
advice for that one and I think I'll ask
you my third most asked question when I
was looking through my comments and
that's really a concern from people who
say things like you know they might
watch my videos and say they love
physics but they've failed some of their
physics courses and they're not sure if
they can continue in the major because
they think they're just going to keep
failing and they'll never get where they
want to be and they sometimes ask me for
advice they're like you know I failed
all my first-year physics courses should
I pull out or how can I get better I
know you probably have a lot of thoughts
about physics education and how it works
but maybe if if you know like a top
piece of advice or something you know
how can someone get better at learning
physics they improve their grades so the
first question I'd ask to someone who
has failed a few courses or who's
finding it challenging is is how much
are you committing one of the biggest
things I see in students is the more
they engage the more the better their
grades know the more they could it's
like anything right you've got a
practice to get better at something and
you have to engage with the content and
go be you know often go beyond what is
the minimum requirement said it pass the
course or just you know I think that
particularly university level there's
been this sort of push to you know like
a lot of if you're if you're still
having
or courses delivered in lecture mode and
you weren't having these lectures these
lectures get recorded and so you're not
engaging with them I dug up my old
lecture notes the other day by accident
and um the level of detail and the
drawings and the stuff you know there's
actually a bit of an skill to how you
would take good notes in a lecture
learning actively yeah I don't think
that that's lectures are not where
you're going to get the best results in
my opinion you need to go off and find
other things that work for you so if you
feel like your lecture your lecture or
your teacher hasn't explained things
really well don't see them yeah most in
my experience most academic first
particularly first-year teachers or
teachers that are teaching smaller
classes and physics is often can be a
smaller cohort they're really interested
in students that are engaged they're
quite happy to give them some time the
other thing I'd really recommend and
your viewers already obviously using
YouTube and engaging with that medium
there's a huge amount of really good
YouTube channels that explain science
principles often physics principles
honestly better than you know a lot of
the teachers I've had in my life I've
made use of not just like popular
science videos but lectures from other
universally online absolutely
you know enroll in yeah enroll in an EDX
course and have a look at what the
videos look like you don't have to go
through the whole course but basically
be proactive find more content sometimes
in physics the challenge is maths it's
actually not necessarily that you don't
get the concept so I often find that
there are people who really understand
the concept you know that oh okay this
is how gravity works and everything you
know falls at the same acceleration
without you know air resistance and
things like that
but but actually there you have trouble
going through the mathematics doing the
algebra linking or linking that to
real-world problems and so actually
working on your maths might be one of
the best things you could do yeah I
definitely agree like maths can be an
obstacle to doing well in physics it's
not the be-all and end-all physics isn't
about maths but it is the language of
physics and in fact maths is just a
language of logic right and science and
so make coming at maths from that point
of view and again I find that some of
the
educational resources for mathematics
are not necessarily the math teachers in
universities but things like Khan
Academy three Brown three Brown you know
that III still after twenty years of
doing this stuff I still find myself
watching those videos and really
thoroughly enjoy I still learn things
from those videos every math majors when
I'm watching his like linear algebra
yeah intuitions I might want that
hey yeah they give us really beautiful
geometric examples and think pictures
throughout pictures to hang on to and
never before have we had more
information available with us so easily
and actually sometimes part of the
challenge is finding the right
information there's so much of it
available you know if you just google
one concept you'll get so many possible
explanations and takes on it and you
know do you trust it and so on Wikipedia
is actually a really good resource yeah
basic stuff it's the most accurate and
so I can link you to other references
exactly alright thank you I really
appreciate your expertise weighing in on
some of these because I think you know
your opinions will really help people
and I've been a bit scared to answer
some of these questions on my own
because you know I worry that my
perspective is a little bit narrow so
it's good to bring someone else in a bit
also like you can do little experiments
at home it's like oh the better right
you can take a magnet magnet a battery a
screw and a wire and you can build a
motor and I'm not gonna tell you how to
do it but then you can try to explain
all right yeah thank you John
no worries and thank you guys for
watching see ya